Marriage is always seemed a little bit
problematic to me,
the idea that a government gets to
decide whether or not you are married
according to a given set of laws or a
religious authority gets to do so.
I was thinking about this as I was in
the process of getting married and
thinking about the fact that honestly,
as much as that paperwork would matter
to the government,
it wouldn't really matter much to me or
to my future wife.
I wanted to find a way to get married
that was deeper,
that was more universal than whatever
sort of legal framework could be thrown
my way by the United States government.
I want it to instead be married by a law
of nature that is possible today,
perhaps for the first time because of
advances in quantum physics,
you wouldn't think it.
Quantum physics tends to be either
highly theoretical or a system that is
used.
For instance,
in cryptography.
However,
quantum entanglement,
one of the essential systems that comes
out of quantum mechanics is one that has
the potential,
I believe,
to serve as a way in which marriage can
be based on a truly universal
foundation.
Quantum entanglement involves two or
more particles becoming effectively one
and the same even if they are separated
across the universe from each other when
they are entangled.
Everything that happens to one
instantaneously happens to the other as
if it had been done to the second
particle.
That quality seems an awful lot like
what marriage is about,
this way in which you can lead separate
lives and yet you still are somehow
bound and whatever comes away of one
person in a relationship also applies to
the other.
So I set about building an apparatus
that would allow my wife and I and
others as well to become entangled,
to become married in a way that no
governmental authority,
no religious authority could say that.
That it was not allowed,
that it was inappropriate.
That gay marriage,
for instance,
would not be an issue that a government
could.
That any sort of relationship at all.
If it was meaningful to you could become
fully manifest as an entangled
relationship,
as a marriage at the basis of all
reality.
The apparatus was very simple.
I used a special sort of crystal which
was able to take sunlight,
photons and bombard two people standing
below the apparatus with those photons
in a way that they themselves became
entangled by the entanglement of the
photons so that while it would not
necessarily be all of them,
while it would not necessarily withstand
all time and space,
they could partake in this process of
entanglement and they could then take
away from it what they wanted to take
away.
That is to say that any quantum system
is extremely delicate.
Entanglement is no exception.
Any measurement that you make has the
effect of collapsing the system.
In other words,
two particles that are entangled if you
check to see if they are entangled,
will become disentangled,
and so likewise to people who are
married by the process of quantum
entanglement,
should they questioned that bond and
start to interrogate it will become
disentangled as well.
So in a sense,
the entanglement operates both literally
and metaphorically.
Literally because I'm using real
equipment that is used for entanglement
for purposes of encryption,
for instance,
to entangle people and people are
becoming genuinely entangled by that
process,
but it is also,
I think more importantly,
the knowledge that that process has
taken place and the way in which that
makes those people behave.
That is what makes for an entanglement
so special as a form of marriage.
The fact that it really has to be taken
on faith ultimately because the quantum
mechanics demands that and relationships
are that way to relationships are
delicate in the sense that quantum
systems are so.
I think that we can actually learn from
subatomic particles how to behave toward
each other in a caring,
longterm relationship.
I think that the metaphor that is
inherent in language and in the common
understanding of a quantum process can
be something that we can apply quite
literally and highly productively in our
everyday lives.
He might say that metaphors are just
metaphors.
No,
like a poem.
How important can it be helped?
Seriously.
Can you take something that was meant
for the enjoyment that you might get
reading a book?
To what extent can you really make use
of it?
I think that metaphor actually is
something that can be used incredibly
productively by taking it literally not
by taking it literally and leaving it at
that,
but recognizing the metaphor for what it
is and finding what happens if you apply
it literally in your life so that in the
case of quantum physics,
because quantum physics is so weird
because quantum particles behave in ways
that are so totally foreign to the way
in which we live,
to our experience of the world.
Much of the discussion of quantum
physics happens metaphorically and the
metaphors can be mined.
I think it can be applied.
I believe in ways that lead through
their literal application to different
ways in which we can relate to each
other in the world.
That is to say that quantum particles
relate to each other in ways that are
entirely different from those with which
we are familiar from those with which we
relate with each other on an everyday
basis.
The way in which we relate to each other
on an everyday basis.
It doesn't always work so well.
We fight.
We have problems communicating,
we go to war,
so might it be possible taking the
quantum realm,
the metaphors that are used to explain
how quantum particles interact and
applying those metaphors literally in
our lives that we made,
realign the way in which we live that
makes us somehow unlike how we were
before and that repositioning,
while it need not be absolute or
permanent,
at least can be something that we can
try out,
can be another way in which we can
consider our relationship with others
and can through that process,
give us more perspective on the myriad
possibilities.
As far as a society where there are 7
billion of us for how that society can
interact and interrelate.